I think if you're a upper-middle class
or you know middle middle class and
strong economically you're doing pretty
good you still have racial obstacles and
other impediments that need to be dealt
with but for the most part you've been
doing pretty well but the working poor
and the working class black Americans
are having a tough time of it and I
certainly arguably even further from the
promised land then when dr. King was
alive and so we have to grapple with
that I think when we look at the report
card out of America that I try to
deliver in the book you look at the you
know look at the mortgage crisis I mean
the greatest bleed off of American
wealth ever what is it over 77 billion
dollars and maybe up to as much as a
hundred and ten twenty billion dollars
you know bland off of black America the
greatest loss of wealth in the history
of this country that's unacceptable
and yet it has occurred with alarming
frequency when we look at health care
for the poor many black people who are
poor use the emergency ward as their
health maintenance organization and by
the time they grapple with diseases in
the emergency ward
you know those diseases have already
progressed and that there's there are
many more complications and crises that
are afoot when we look at single headed
households that are dealing with
economic downturns they are even much
more vulnerable when we look at the the
buffeting forces on the black family the
over incarceration of young black men
the hyper incarceration and putting into
jail and into detention of young black
men which means that poor City Schools
become warehouses for jails and then
ultimately the penitentiary so when we
look at those issues among many of us
persistent inequality in the workplace
the lagging behind economically of black
people in terms of wage structure the
segregation and Horne's heaney of
working-class black people among the
most low you know among the lowest wage
workers in the nation when you put all
that stuff together
poor black people are having a tough
time
and struggling against the odds